foreign
so here we are standing in front of a
row of trash bins trying to figure out
which bins do I put this cup in
let's give it a try
raise your hand if you think this cup
goes in the landfill bin
now what about the recycling bin
now what about the composting bin
okay now raise your hands if you're not
quite sure
looks like most of you sorting waste is
really challenging
most people want to do the right thing
but the system is so confusing they make
their best guess and move on
today I want to talk to you all about
composting waste but first what is
composting
it's a natural process driven by
microorganisms that break down waste
into soil
while composting can happen in a small
backyard scale most composting waste
that's collected is take it to is taken
to a large industrial scale facility
where it's treated there
in a large industrial scale composting
facility this natural process requires
very specific conditions
carbon to nitrogen ratio of 30 to 1.
moisture content between 50 to 60
percent and the continual mixing and
adding of oxygen that produces aerobic
conditions that naturally generates heat
above 130 degrees Fahrenheit which
ultimately breaks down waste into soil
did you catch all that
the takeaway here is that composting is
a complex but very useful process that
breaks down waste into soil
when sent to landfill organic materials
like food scraps and lawn clippings
produce methane a potent greenhouse gas
but when scented compost organic
materials don't produce methane this is
a very good thing
however
the composting of supposedly compostable
food containers
is a different story
the idea of compostable packaging is a
lovely one we imagine that the cups both
plate spoons utensils and straws that we
use to eat our food and then so
carefully place in the composting bin
will be sent to a facility where it will
break down turn into soil and return to
our food system
however I'm here to deliver some bad
news
the majority of the infrastructure in
the United States cannot manage this
type of waste
about 90 percent of all composting
facilities reject compostable packaging
so it's sent to landfill where it
doesn't biodegrade it's not composted
and it certainly does not turn into food
long story short compostable packaging
for the most part does not get composted
I uncovered this problem at my last job
I launched the sustainability program
for the largest food delivery platform
in the world
it was regulatory pressure competition
and consumer demand to find something
more sustainable than the single-use
plastic so popularly used in food
delivery
composting compostable packaging seems
like the optimal Choice it looked good
it felt good and surely it had to be
better than the alternative right
turns out there are three pervasive
issues with compostable Packaging
it's not standardized there's little to
no regulatory oversight and there's a
misalignment between composters and
manufacturers
the materials used to make compostable
packaging vary widely from plant-based
Plastics to plant-based fibers to even
some fake look-alikes all with varying
ability of actually breaking down
this is confusing not only for consumers
but also for composters
second there's little to no regulatory
oversight while the FTC does have some
guidelines on how to Market compostable
products there's no National regulation
of what a compostable product is while
materials can be used to make it or what
standards an item must meet to be
considered compostable
lastly there's a misalignment of
incentives between packaging
manufacturers and composters packaging
manufacturers make and sell packaging
while composters make and sell soil
packaging manufacturers are focused on
making making products that serve
consumer needs not that break down
safely into compost
this broken system exists because of the
gap between packaging manufacturers
composters and regulators
the state of California has taken a
first step in attempting to address
these three challenges with one bill
ab1201
the bill tries to standardize
compostable packaging in the state
as it stands now this bill falls short
super high level the bill essentially
states that compostable products must be
able to break down in a composting
facility within 180 days
this means that packaging manufacturers
can make products that last 180 days
that's six months in a composting
facility
meanwhile new technologies have improved
the processing time in composting
facilities from 180 to less than 90 days
which means if these facilities were to
introduce compostable packaging into
their services it would more than double
their processing time
no ones or composters don't want
consumer packaging waste in their
composting streams
but it's not just a matter of processing
time
composters also reject compostable
products because it introduces
contamination without providing
additional nutrients into the soil
for example composting waste is often
contaminated with other material types
particularly things like plastic which
don't break down in a composting system
additionally toxins such as pfas can be
found in certain compostable materials
while having an enforceable regulation
in the state of California is a good
first step future policy must align with
how the system actually works
ultimately what's most important is that
we reduce the amount of waste we produce
it's critical that we enable and
encourage the use of reusables and build
systems that reduce waste altogether
however sometimes reusables are not an
option so a pragmatic solution for
disposable packaging must align
incentives across all players
so how do we bridge the gap between
composters and manufacturers
we need mandates that standardize the
safety and materials used in compostable
materials so that there's no
contamination in the composting stream
we need more stringent policy and
oversight to force composters and
manufacturers to collaborate
and lastly as money gets pumped into
sustainable Technologies both on the
packaging side as well as the composting
side
we need policy to get updated and be
enforced in order to keep incentives
aligned
so yes it's true the system does not
work well today
however I still encourage you to try
your best every time you sort your trash
let's go back to our cup
which bin do we put this cup in
well on the bottom of the cup it tells
us it's compostable
so do we compost it
you may be surprised to hear me say this
but my answer is yes
as I mentioned there's a lot of
innovation happening in the system today
both on the composting side and on the
packaging side that Innovation is driven
by the demand shown by consumers so yes
the system does not work well today but
it doesn't mean it won't in the future
what's most important is that we
continue to show the demand for more
stringent policy that ensures that
compostable packaging can actually be
composted
together we can all help reduce our
waste thank you
[Applause]
thank you